il s'agit de l'un des plus gros ver sur
le plan matériel pour la russie selon
moscou le croiseur lance-missiles moskva
vaisseau amiral de la flotte russe en
mer noire avec plus de 500 personnes à
bord est désormais gravement endommagées
en raison d'un incendie des munitions
exploser à bord et l'équipage a été
entièrement évacué mais pour kiev la
version des faits est tout autre les
autorités locales affirment que le
bateau a été touchée par des missiles
ukrainien et que la russie devait
évacuer les marins à bord en urgence des
missiles neptune qui protège la mer
noire ont causé d'importants dégâts ce
navire russe gloire à l'ukraine le
navire avait pris part à une attaque au
cours de laquelle 19 marins ukrainiens
avaient été capturés fin février
les opérations en mer noire sont très
importantes côté russe pour soutenir les
forces terrestres dans le sud et l'est
le moskva et le deuxième navire russe à
subir d'importants dommages depuis le
début de la guerre